a climate protesters from just stop oil
have caused more disruption on the M25
for a fourth day in a row this morning
it comes despite a court injunction
against the group and a warning from
Essex police that it is only a matter of
time before someone is killed during a
protest well during rush hour this
morning the UK's busiest Motorway had to
be closed in two areas as police
officers attempted to remove protesters
who climbed onto overhead signs
meanwhile Kent Police say they also
proactively arrested five suspected
activists near the M25 in a car with
climbing equipment and Banners while
crime correspondent Martin Brandt is
near Junction 8 on the M25 in Surrey
where those protests have taken place
and you can see the motorway moving
again Martin have those protests now
been ceased for the day
uh yeah I think they're probably over
now we've had a fourth day running of
protests or actions as uh just stop oil
insist on calling them
um perhaps not as much disruption today
as there have been in past days previous
days perhaps suggests that the police
are using more officers to uh to combat
the protest and are getting better at
dealing with them I mean it's um it's a
tricky thing for the police to climb up
gantrism remove people protesters safely
where they have been doing that this
morning on a couple of occasions the M25
has been closed there were two arrests
by Surrey police around these Junctions
seven and eight
um there was one arrest in Essex
um the Metropolitan Police were dealing
with a protester around the Waltham
cross area I'm not quite sure how that
ended but it does appear that from now
on all well certainly in the last few
days all protesters have been arrested
that seems to be the pattern of police
Behavior police reaction and police of
course have up to the language they've
been using they've talked about these
protests going Beyond protest and
becoming criminality so they've
certainly sent a warning to protesters
that they will be dealt with in a very
firm way and to that end the chief
Constable of Essex
J Harrington has been talking about has
how his force is dealing with the
protesters and this is what B.J
Harrington said we have been telling
just stop oil all the time that
motorways are dangerous places I think
it is only a matter of time before
somebody gets killed
the only way this is going to stop is if
just stop oil frankly grow up and
realize they are putting people's lives
at risk I don't believe at the moment
that that is really going to make much
difference to these uh these protests
and the Coalition just up or it's a
coalition of various campaign groups
insist that their protest will continue
um the police appear to be dealing with
it as I said earlier a little quicker
minimizing the disruption to the M25 on
a daily basis but the M25 was stopped so
a couple of places I think in in both
directions
the problem is the tactic of just stop
oil is to put protesters onto gantries
they're climbing up on gantries and
around the M25 there are more than 600
gantries and the police have already
admitted they can't guard all of them
okay Martin thanks very much